voilà la célèbre numéro 9 puits canadien
passe à l'immortalité
cette célèbre photo de maurice richard
les jambes zoo qui a été prise par
conrad poirier un pionnier du
photojournalisme au québec
la qualité des photos et elle est
excellente et nous avons demandé aux
photojournalistes jacques nadeau de
visiter l'exposition consacrée à conrad
poirier où on retrouve des célébrités
comme charles trenet on y voit aussi le
mot real d'antan c'est des villages
d'autrefois un peu et un mouvement dans
cette image lol ça ça décrit très bien
montréal dans cette époque là je pense
qu'il était un très bon observateur oui
on sent un peu engageant toutes les
photos qui se promenait un peu partout
muni d'un des premiers appareils photos
portatif conrad poirier travaillé pour
différents journaux et revues de
montréal mais ils s'amusaient aussi à
immortaliser des scènes de la vie
quotidienne
cette photo elle est splendide jeune
boxeur site sert d'inertie une photo de
cette époque qu'elle pris le temps
d'aller se promener campagne des
photographies des gens avec des râteaux
des jeunes filles comme ça
qualifiée d' excentrique on sait très
peu de choses sur conrad poirier qui
classait méticuleusement ses photos
maniaque de l'image il est décédé en
1968 à l'âge de 55 ans c'est drôle parce
que monsieur voirie à une vie
personnelle très obscur donc on sait peu
de choses de lui il s'est jamais marié
vécu dans la maison paternelle toute sa
vie avec le lieu précis en douceur il
était fan de cinéma américain
le fonds conrad poirier détenu par
bibliothèque et archives nationales du
québec contient près de 23 mai photo et
il s'agit du fonds le plus consulté
donc c'est un fonds accessibles en ligne
on peut se le voir deux chez nous
directement dans la chaleur de notre
foyer à l'aide de banshee numérique
c'est la faune le plus consulté au
québec mais aussi consulte à travers le
mans oui il est très consulté à travers
le monde sur les plateformes monkey
notamment outil un outil pedia donc on a
fait des projets de mise en valeur et il
a été utilisé de partout à travers le
monde pour une stricte des articles des
fois en japonais tandis qu'il passe à
l'histoire chorale poirier et disparus
sans avoir pu goûter à la célébrité
jacques nadeau a une pensée pour ce
défricheur savait difficile aussi
ségalis et vit avec ça il travaille pour
des journaux mais est ce qu'elle est on
nous avait il y avait pas les journaleux
beaucoup de photos à ce moment là donc
c'est de réussir à gagner sa vie ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal